- So wait, so when are we going
to get, asking for a friend,
a "Schitts Creek" movie
or something like that?
- [Audience] Yeah!
- Exactly!
Exactly.
(audience cheering)
I know what the people want!
- I honestly, I miss the show so much.
- And you should!
It's like one of the
greatest shows ever to exist!
- [Eugene] I know.
- This is a show
that literally family, friends,
we could have nothing
in common politically or
religiously speaking,
- I know.
- and we love this show.
- It's so good, yeah.
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] It's such a good show.
- I absolutely loved doing the show,
and I do know that when
we took the show out
after six seasons, it was
the right time to take it out
because we could not
have finished the series
on a greater high.
So, that was it.
We took it out, and we've always said,
certainly my son Daniel says,
"If we come up with an idea that really
comes up to the same level as
where we finished the show,
or even higher creatively,
that's the time to come
out with a project.
A movie or a show or whatever it is.
We have never given up on "Schitts Creek".
There hopefully will be a future
in some capacity to it.
But it really depends on what that is
- [Kelly] The idea, yeah.
- and when we can get
everybody together again.
- Oh my God,
what an amazing cast!
Yeah, the whole thing, it was magical!
- [Eugene] It was, wasn't it?
- [Audience and Kelly] Yeah!